Okay,
so we're going to talk about piaget
today and as I believe I mentioned to
you before,
Psj was perhaps the 20 20th centuries
for most developmental psychologist.
He didn't regard himself as a
psychologist.
However,
fact,
a lot of the people who've been great
psychologists have come in from outside
the field.
It's often engineers,
for example,
engineers that helped us establish most
of our statistics anyways.
Piaget,
I suppose would have regarded himself
more as a biologist be called themselves
a genetic epistemologist,
and by genetic he didn't mean the genes
that organize your cells and spin you up
out of nothing.
He meant beginnings as in genesis and
then an epistemologist with someone who
was interested in how structures of
knowledge emerge and how they're
constituted.
So we actually thought of himself as a
biological philosopher now know one of
the things that's kind of sad about
learning about great theories is that
you'll hardly ever learned about how
peculiar that people who formulate them
are.
Because generally they're
extraordinarily interesting people you
know,
and that that in some ways that often
they get sanitized in some way once
they've become respectable.
And that's really quite unfortunate.
Piaget was really a genius.
He was offered a position at a large
museum,
and I remember,
I remember correctly,
it was perhaps it wasn't director,
but it was the position of approximately
that stature.
He was offered that when he was 10 years
old,
he'd written a paper on Mollusk behavior
which was published and his parents told
the museum people that he,
of course they didn't know he was 10,
you know,
that he probably wasn't up for the job
at that time.
So,
but that gives you some example,
some idea about the magnitude of his
intellect and Piaget wrote a lot.
And you know,
usually what you hear about if you study
piaget in North America,
if you hear about piaget,
you hear about his stages of
development,
sensory motor,
etc.
And uh,
that really wasn't what piaget was all
that interest to Vietnam.
There wAs something about the idea of
countable stages that seem to appeal to
north american developmental
psychologists,
but piaget didn't really regard that
necessarily as either the central or the
most important part of this theoretical
edifice.
Um,
and you know,
part of what piaget has been criticized
for in recent years is that the stages
don't necessarily occur either as he
described her in the order that he
described,
but in some ways he wouldn't have found
that particularly distressing because it
was more of an attempt to explain how
the personality emerged out.
Nothing in some ways because in some
ways you've kind of emerged out of
nothing,
you know,
and it's not that easy to figure out for
piaget in some ways you've sort of
booted up.
Although he wouldn't haVe used that
metaphor obviously having existed in the
time before.
That was a commonly known phenomena.
So
he also was concerned abouT high level
metaphysical problems.
And so one of the things that really
motivated piaget was the contradiction
between science and religion.
That was very painful for him.
And one of the things that he had set
out to do as a young man was to bridge
the gap between science and religion.
And in some ways you might think about
that in relationship to the sorts of
things we talked about last class is
that
he was attempting to bridge the gap
between a description of the world and a
prescriptive description of the world,
which means what the world is and how
the world should be or what the world is
and how you should act.
and
I think that's the most straightforward
way of thinking about the division
between religion and science because you
need to know how to act.
You can think about it as a division
between morality and science or you can
think about it as a division between
behavioral wisdom and science,
which I think is even a better way of
thinking about it because it,
it takes the specifically religious
element out of it.
so,
but anyways,
piaget wanted to devote his life to
solving that problem.
And I would say that's what he did.
He also identified an interesting stage
that you also hear very little about,
but seems to be to be something worthy
of note and also worthy of
consideration.
He thought that many people in their
late adolescence went through a
messiaNic stage.
And what he meant by that was that when
late adolescents or young adults,
we're trying to orient themselves in the
world,
they were trying to figure out how they
might plot their pAth forward in life so
that they actually made a difference,
you know,
so they started to become concerned
about the state of the world and about
their role in determining that state and
getting interested in and perhaps
involved in large scale political or
social movements.
And he was the only psychologists that
I've ever seen who actually identified
that as a stage,
but it's switched.
We're thinking about,
you know,
because it certainly is the case that
many young people do pass through a
stage that's something like that.
And,
um,
it's interesting to speculate on it as a
standard part of human development.
Now.
I think it's probably more
characteristic of people with certain
personality types.
So I suspect if you're more extroverted
and you're more open,
um,
particularly more open,
which is the creativity dimension in the
big five that you're more likely to be
politically and socially,
uh,
compelled,
you know,
so we know,
for example,
that openness is a very good predictor
of things like political liberalism and
uh,
you know,
certainly a lot of the millennial
movements and that religious movements
that you see on campus that have what
would arguably be a political base
seemed to be associated with high
openness.
So maybe that stage doesn't occur in
everyone's life,
but it certainly seems to occur in many
people's lives.
Okay.
So now you might ask yourself,
well,
what was piaget up to?
And while he wanted to figure out a lot
of things and he was interested in very,
very fundamental issues.
So for example,
his theories dealt with things like
number in space.
Product can't see that very well.
It doesn't matter.
I'll tell you what it says,
time and speed,
permanent objects.
How did,
how did a person developed the notion of
what constituted a permanent object?
How do you know when one thing is the
same?
When it changes into something
different,
so for example,
if you pour one bit of liquid from one
container into another,
how do you know that the amount of
liquid is the same?
Um,
how do children develop their ideas of
chance and causality?
How do they develop their concerns about
morality and their moral knowledge?
What,
what the,
what are they doing when they're
playing?
And I think actually piaget's most
fundamental contribution as far as I'm
concerned,
came in his studies and analysis of play
and also to some degree his,
his analysis of dreams and he also spent
a lot of time giving serious
consideration to the role that imitation
played in,
in the scaffolding of the human
personality.
And so,
um,
so some of the,
so,
uh,
piaget believed that,
well,
I think this is the easiest way to talk
about it.
Actually will use this diagram here.
So I'll shut this light,
go off.
It took me a long time to construct this
diagram.
So not because it's all that technically
difficult,
but it took a while to think it up.
So I want to give you a little bit about
background to it.
So I imagine that
one of the things that distinguishes a
human being from a computational device
say,
or at least the standard sort of
computational devices that are primary
cognitive problem,
is how to perceive the world so that we
can act in it so that we can get what we
need to have or one.
Okay,
so all three of those things are roughly
equivalent importance,
right?
You have to be able to perceive and you
have to be able to act because if you
can't act and he can't get what you need
and if you can't get what you need,
then of course there isn't an you.
And so we're trying to always solve
those problems simultaneously and we're
also trying to do it in a way that's
sustainable.
Now,
what that means in part is that the
knowledge structures of human beings are
organized or or they are organized along
those three dimensions in those three
dimensions also constitute the problem
space.
In some sense,
that has to be addressed for a solUtion
to be useful.
So not only do you have to be able to
perceive in some accurate manner,
but the accuracy is determined in part
on in terms of whether or not the way
that you're perceiving helps you pursue
something that you want to pursue and
then the utility of wanting to pursue
something is dependent to some degree on
the relationship between the utility of
that and the things that you need to
continue to survive.
Now some psychologists have addressed
that by thinking about such things as
fundamental drives,
you know,
and that was mostly a behavioral idea in
some ways and the drive might be hunger
and,
and the idea of a drive would be that
hunger is a motivator that helps you put
together a strings of motor behaviors
that are sort of run out in automatic
sequence so that you can,
you can get the end that you want and
continue one perhaps to fulfill another
drive.
But the idea of drive is a little bit on
the oversimplified side.
although it has its place.
I think that you can conceptualize the
relationship between all of these by
thinking in the following manner.
So imagine first of all that people are
after something,
generally speaking.
Now,
if you look at us,
you can kind of tell that were the sorts
of creatures that are after things and
the way that you can tell that is first
of all that we can move and do so
frequently,
so we're always on a voyage of some sort
of a journey of some sort from point one
to point to or from point a to point b.
I would say as well that that's also the
hallmark of a simple story.
If you're telling someone a story,
generally what you do is you tell them
about a time that you were somewhere and
then you did some things and you went
somewhere else.
It's a very,
very simple story.
Now the advantage of thinking about it
as a story is that it helps you
understand that the entire cognitive
structure can't be reduced to
necessarily anything that's,
for example,
that's drive like you have to think
about it as more personality like and so
you want something you orient yourself
towards.
Now,
the way you do that,
generally speaking,
is with your sensory and your conceptual
systems,
right?
So for example,
if you want to walk towards the door,
then you turn your head and you make
yourself a mortal of the door and that
model has to be bounded by its relevance
to your action so you know the things
that are going to be relevant to you
about the door,
for example,
might be whether or not it's tall enough
for you to walk through or whether or
not the door is open or closed so that
you can,
as you're walking towards it,
you can organize your body so that you
can interact with the object as you see
fit.
Now you pick your goals,
know search for all sorts of different
reasons and some of those reasons are
more fundamental than others.
So for example,
fundamental by fundamental,
I would mean likely what I mean by
fundamental,
something like evolutionarily ancient,
you know,
so the,
the older,
the necessity or the older,
the system that's evolved to to allow
you to pursue the necessity,
the more fundamental it is and there's
not.
There's ways of identifying what
constitutes the fundamental elements of
goal seeking behavior,
and you can do that in part by comparing
yourself to other animals,
you know,
and so mammals,
for example,
all seem to jet to experience something
that you might regard as anger or at
least defensive aggression.
They're all hungry,
you know,
they all have the,
the,
they all act as if they're,
they're,
uh,
they highly value sexual behavior and so
forth.
And so those,
you can't really think of those things
as a specifically human.
They're a lower level than that now.
So at a fundamental level,
you have biological systems that are
setting forth what might constitute a
goal.
And you can think about that.
You can think that what the system is
doing is setting the goal or you can
think that the system is driving
behavior.
But a better way of thinking about it is
that the fundamental motivation
motivational system sets up a framework
that's like a personality that then acts
in the world.
And so this personality has something in
mind that it wants.
It has a collection of perceptions that
organize itself around that thing that
it wants,
and then it has a plan or associated
motor behaviors that it can lay out in
the world that will take it from the
point where it is to the point that it
wants to be okay now.
So once you know that,
then you can start to think about these
plans or these goals or these stories or
these frameworks.
I think those are all.
You can even think about them as games.
In some ways.
You can think about them at different
levels of complexity.
Now what piaget was trying to do in part
was to describe how a framework of this
sort or a sub,
a sub element of personality might
develop itself and complexity over time.
So,
so the diagram I have here before he
shows these little oval like figures and
in the bottom left hand corner there's a
box that says what is in the top right
hand corner.
There's a box that says what should be,
and then there's some arrows showing a
planned sequence of behavior.
And the idea is that you have a sense of
where you are and you have a sense of
where you're going and that constitutes
the framework within which you're
looking at the world.
And then within that framework there's
different things that you can do with
your body in order to advance from the
first point,
the second point.
Now it's important to understand that
this sort of thing is grounded in
behavior and not in conception because
it helps you also understand the nature
of these fundamental elements of
personality.
The fundamental elements of personality
or not descriptions of the world are
tools for acting in the world,
including the associated behaviors.
Now,
whether they're behavioral or to some
degree depends on their level of
abstraction.
So,
so here's how you.
How to think about that.
So imagine that you say that someone's a
good person and you might say,
well that's a description of the and
that.
And when you think about description,
you tend to think about description in
the way that you would describe an
object in the world,
like a scientific description.
But when you talk about someone as a
good person,
you're actually not describing them as
an object in the world,
wouldn't even describe yourself as an
object in the world,
that way what you're doing is using a
shorthand to represent a higher the
hierarchical arrangement of their
personality and you can get away with it
because when you say good person to
someone,
they already have an understanding of
good person and they know what that
hierarchy is and so you don't have to
explain the whole thing to them and you
can understand each other without even
necessarily knowing exactly the details
of what you're talking about.
But I'm going to tell you now what I
think you mean when you say that sort of
thing.
So imagine that good person is a
description at the very,
at the top end of a hierarchy.
Okay?
because good,
the good is a very high level
philosophical abstraction.
It's a high level value.
Be good.
Okay.
So what does that mean?
If you decompose it?
Well,
we'll do it in a relatively
straightforward manner.
One that isn't really.
It's more observational than
philosophical.
So let's say you take,
you take someone who's a 40 year old
mother for the sake of argument and who
will say she also has a job.
So if she's a good person and she's a
mother,
you might think that's one sub element
of her personality.
If she's a good person is being a good
parent.
Right?
And I think you've put person above
parent in the hierarchy because to be a
good person you can be a good parent
without being a good person,
but it's hard to see how you could be a
good person without being a good parent.
So,
and maybe if you're a good person,
you're more than a good parent,
you know you're probably a good partner
and maybe you're good at your job and
like there are,
there are large domains of activity that
you're good at or good in and with some
your behavior across that are average
year behavior across that or something
like that.
Then you ended up reasonably being
described as a good person.
Maybe you're a good friend as well and
so good person has levels of hierarchy
underneath it and were.
And then each of those things that have
levels of hierarchy,
each of those entities at the level of
hierarchy,
right underneath,
good person can also be decomposed.
So we're going to decompose them and
we're gonna see what happens.
Because partly what happens is if you
decompose them,
you get right to the bottom.
It's not an infinite decomposition.
And so I also think this is one way that
you can think about the relationship
between the mind and the body because of
the relationship between the mind and
the body is a very tricky thing because
the mind seems to be made of stuff
that's other than the body.
And I think there's some truth to that
partly because we don't really
understand consciousness,
but there are.
But that's a complex problem and I think
you can get a fair ways in addressing
the mind body problem without having to
drag into the problem of consciousness.
So okay,
so we could say,
well good person sub element of that is
good parent.
Then you might think,
well what is it that you need to be
doing to be a good parent?
And we might say,
well,
you have to have a good job,
maybe that's one up in the hierarchy,
but whatever,
you have to have a good job because
otherwise you can't provide for your
children and you have to be able to care
for the children.
You might say,
well,
someoNe's good at caring for children
and then you might ask them,
well,
what does it mean to be good at caring
for children?
And then you have to sort of think of
the sub elements that would go into
caring for children.
And so one of them here is you have to
know how to cook a meal or complete a
meal and then you also have to know how
to play with the baby so we could
concentrate on playing with the baby.
And so what you do when you're playing
with a baby,
you might play peekaboo.
You might tickle the baby and you might
clean the baby.
Okay?
Now you start thinking,
well obviously once you're starting to
get down to that level of detail.
So that's a high resolution model,
right?
You're,
you're starting to move from a low
resolution model,
good person to a high resolution model,
which are what are precisely the
multitude of elements that make up being
a good person.
Well,
if you're playing peekaboo with a baby,
for example,
all of a sudden you're doing something
that's not exactly conceptual.
Being a good person is conceptual,
but playing peekaboo isn't conceptual
and the reason it's not conceptual,
it's because he actually have to move
your hands to do it.
So if you get to a high enough level of
resolution in the description of a
personality,
what you start describing our patterns
of behavior,
now they have associated,
you know they have an associated
motivational framework and a viewpoint
that goes along with them so that I
would say,
well,
even while you're playing peekaboo with
the baby,
that the,
the element of you that's playing
peekaboo is best described as a
subpersonality.
It's a playful subpersonality and then
it's the subpersonality that
specifically knows how and is motivated
to play peekaboo.
But what it's composed of is no longer
as subpersonality it starting to be
composed of actual movements.
So,
and then underneath that,
if you go to higher resolution,
like,
okay,
what's the movement composed of?
Well obviously you start to have to talk
about musculature and then if you go
below that,
it's molecular movements and so on,
but,
but once you're down below a voluntary
movement,
there's really no you there anymore,
right?
You sort of fade into unconsciousness
because you know how to go like this,
but you don't exactly know how to move
the specific muscles that enable you to
go like that.
Or even if you do,
you don't know how to twitch the muscle
fibers or something like that.
Right?
There's some law.
You don't know how to operate the cells.
There's some level of resolution
underneath voluntary motor control that
that basically runs on automatic and to
some degree you're capable of like
steering it,
but you're not really capable of.
You're certainly not capable of being
conscious of it.
So the,
the abstract moral conception,
which is also a description,
good person hits the world at the level
of motor output now and a lot like even
your sensory movement.
A lot of outs,
motor outPut,
right?
Because a lot of what you're doing with
your eyes is moving them,
so all right,
now what does that have to do with
piaget?
Well,
one of the ways of understanding piaget
is that he built.
He was really interested in
understanding how that entire system
came to be and his theory is a bottom up
theory.
He says,
okay,
yeah,
this is this.
This is.
He hasn't said this,
but it's a very useful way of thinking
about it because piaget believed that
you started with small elements of what
he called reflexive behavior and then
you learn to chain them together and
increasingly complex structures and then
you chain those complex structures into
more and more complex structures and so
on and so forth until you built up the
entire hierarchy.
But you tended to start from the bottom.
So piaget was particularly interested in
what the minimum conditions were for
something to emerge into the world so
that he could build itself out of
nothing.
And that's really what he was interested
in when he was starting to talk about
infant development.
And so piaget's hypothesis with
something like this,
well kill babies are born very,
very immature.
You might even say that they're born
premature,
so I'm a human baby.
If you took a mammal,
have read about human size and you said,
well what's its average gestation period
across the animal kingdom?
You'd find out that for an animal of our
size we should have a gestation period
of pregnancy period of two years.
So we don't.
We hAve a gestation period of nine
months.
And so you might ask,
well why is that?
And the answer is complicated.
Obviously you've got to hear some of the
reasons as far as people can tell 'em we
have big heads and they've really been
expanding rapidly over particularly over
the last 2 million years.
But let's say since we split off from
chimps,
that's about 6 million years.
We have very,
very large heads and you know,
if you look at a baby,
a baby's head is pretty damn
disproportionately large compared to its
body.
Like a baby's like a third hat.
And so even when the baby's little nine
months old,
well,
nine months after conception and maybe a
year and three months before it's
supposed to be born,
it's head is already extremely big.
Now you think,
well what's the problem with that?
And the problem with that is while the
bigger your head is,
the harder it is to be born.
And you might say,
well why haven't the pelvic areas of
human beings adjusted females in
particular adjusted so that they could
handle the birth with a larger head and
the answer to that as well,
they have to some degree,
which is why women have wider hips that
men do.
But the problem is is evolution is a
conservative business and it can only in
some sense tinker with what it's already
got.
And so if you look at the basic bought
your basic body plan,
your basic body plan in it,
most in its most fundamental levels was
established some tens of millions or
even hundreds of millions of years ago.
And then the basic mammalian body plan
was established say 60 million years
ago.
And so if you go,
I went to the smithsonian wants and they
have a skeleton museum at the
smithsonian.
It's sort of like a zoo for,
for skeletons and it's really
interesting place to go because you can
see much more help and like mammals are
when you see their skeleton.
So for example,
if you see a bat skeleton,
it looks just like a human skeleton,
except the fingers are really,
really long.
But it's the rest of it's like,
yeah,
that's basically the same skeleton as a
human being.
IT's just that the pieces have blown up
in size or shrunk or,
or,
or contorted or something like that.
But it's exactly the same damn
structure.
So as,
as the brain was growing in the skull
was getting larger and women,
women's bodies had to adapt to that
while there was parameters within which
the body had to work.
And it turns out that if you make the
hips any wider and you make the hole in
the middle of the many bigger than the
hips start to lose structural integrity.
And the other thing that starts to
happen is the woman can't run.
So there's this weird,
you imagine that evolution takes place
within this set of constraints and so
what's happening is the baby gets born
way earlier.
The women's hips are wider with the
larger pelvic whole but not so wide.
They can't run and not so wide.
They're not strong and the baby's head
is collapsible roughly because the bones
aren't completely fused at birth and so
generally,
especially if it's a larger baby,
if it's born,
when it,
when it emerges just after birth,
it's head is quite compressed.
Cone Shaped even so.
And that's hard on the baby,
but it's not nearly as hard on the baby
or the mother as not being born at all.
So anyways,
babies are born pretty premature and you
know,
that puts a tremendous burden on human
parents because of course the child is,
I can't even walk for the first year.
Whereas you take a deer when a deer is
born or an animal like that,
you know,
it's three minutes later,
it's wobbling around on its feet and
then it's running away from lions the
next morning.
It's like,
that's,
that's not us.
You think,
why not?
It's well were born very premature and
very,
very vulnerable and you know,
it's a major load on the,
on the parents.
Anyways.
One question piaget was interested in
is,
well,
what exactly is a baby born with?
And he thought,
well,
they're born with a couple of things.
One is here's three things.
In a sense you might think they're born
with a couple of reflexes and what you
might think of a as a reflex is that
it's a built in module of sensory motor
capability and maybe it and it,
you know,
maybe there's a motivational element to
it as well.
So I would say it's a built in
subpersonality and it's a very narrow.
Subpersonality has a very narrow cast.
And so one thing,
one thing babies can do is route.
So if you touch them on the site,
if they're cheap,
then they route.
And basically what that means is that
they use their mouth and their head to
search for something to latch onto with
their mouth.
And that would generally be a nipple.
So they come pre wired to be able to use
their mouth and their tongue and certain
muscles have their head in order to
figure out how to feed and that's
actually a very complicated behavior.
And so one of the things you see with
babies is that their mouth and their
tongue is quite wired up already.
So if you're looking at a newborn baby,
the intelligent part of the baby in some
sense like the part that's already there
is very much oriented towards health and
its tongue.
And that's sorta like freud's idea of an
oral stage in some sense.
Although,
you know,
you could debate that,
but that's partly why freud thought that
way.
He knew that babies were very mouth
oriented.
It once they can start using their hands
and they can pick up objects.
What do they do with objects?
I put them in their mouth.
Right?
Why?
Well,
because that's what babies do partly,
but that's not the only reason.
It's like if you look at the.
Okay,
so back in the fifties,
forties,
maybe even earlier than that,
there is a neurosurgeon named what?
Wilder penfield who worked at the
montreal neurological institute and he
was one of the people who first did,
um,
surgery for example,
for epilepsy.
So if you hAve epilepsy,
what happens is generally you kind of
have a short circuit,
there's a malfunctioning set of neurons
usually in the hippocampus and they've
produced like a positive feedback
electrical circuit and it's like a
little electrical storm and it'll start
in damaged tissue and that's spread
across the whole brain.
And one of the things the early
neurosurgeons were doing was dividing
the brain into to stop the hemisphere
that had the damage from being able to
spread pathological electric electricity
across the entire brain.
Now when you're doing brain surgery,
you don't want to take out anything that
isn't absolutely necessary.
And so one of the things the brain
surgeons do and still do and still do is
that they do brain surgery.
When you're conscious,
which is quite a horrifying thought
really,
because you know your head is stuck in
this little machine that doesn't let it
move.
and then they're poking around in your
brain and you have to tell them what's
going on while you're doing it.
And if you start being able to respond,
then I presume they assume that they've
made a mistake and you know,
tough luck for you at any ways.
Penfield was interested not only in you
know,
conducting his surgery properly,
but also in mapping out the brain to
figure out,
well,
what parts of it could use and you know,
do you have to keep and what parts can
you maybe get rid of?
And part of that was because there was
an idea for a long time among
neurologists called equal potentiality,
which meant that the cortex was an
undifferentiated mass of tissue and you
can take out parts of it without really
much loss of function at all.
Which that turned out not to be exactly
right.
Although it wasn't as stupid as an idea
as it might seem,
because the cortex is less
differentiated than other parts of the
brain.
But it turns out that if you take out
parts of it,
like the prefrontal cortex,
the damage that it does is not
immediately evident.
But if you watch the person for any
length of time will usually their lives
fall apart if their prefrontal cortex is
being damaged enough.
Anyway.
So penfield was trying to figure out
what the brain does and so he was using
electrodes to touch the surface and what
he found,
if you imagine that this is the frontal
part of your brain here,
and it's called that because it's at the
front,
right?
And so there's a back part of it has to
do more with sensory processing and then
there's a fissure down the middle.
And on The front side of the fisher
there's an area that's roughly triangle
shaped on the back of the fisher,
there's another area that's roughly
triangle shaped and the front part,
if you touch it with a,
with an electrode like up the right
current,
obviously,
then people will report feeling
something on different parts of their
body.
And then if you touch the part that's
behind the fisher,
so roughly about here,
so then they'll,
they'll be inclined to move or feel the
impulse to move.
And so what,
what then feel did was draw a little map
of what parts of the brain were
connected to,
what sensory sensations in the body and
what parts of the brain were contained
connected to what motor sensations and
he.
He built this thing called a homerun
keyless.
It's a little,
it's a little picture and the picture is
of this creature that's laid out on the
cortex.
It's sort of like a dismembered body in
some sense,
and the size of each part corresponds to
the amount of tissue that's devoted to
processing that brain or that bodily
area.
And what you see is very,
very interesting because if you look,
there's a sensory homonculus.
ThAt's how your body looks to your brain
from a century perspective.
And there's a motor home oculus,
which is how your body looks to your
brain from the perspective of being able
to operate it.
What you see for example,
is with both the sensory and the motor
cortex.
The hand is as big as the whole body and
the thumb is as big as the rest of the
hand.
And then the mouth and the tongue are
also that big and so is the face.
So you've got this little itty bitty
body because what are you,
what are you going to do with your back?
You know,
you,
you can't pick up anything with your
back and you're also not very good.
Really your sensory perception on your
back is not very high resolution.
So if I had one of you stand up and I
put three fingers on your back this far
apart and I said,
how many fingers were there?
You wouldn't be able to tell.
You'd say one probably,
but you can't tell even if you space
them out quite a bit if you pushed
simultaneously.
Whereas on the surface of the hand you
can tell immediately because this is a
high resolution part of your body.
And of course you know you can really
move your little tentatively,
technically appendages here and they're
highly wired up to the brain as well and
very,
very sensitive.
But the reason I told you all that,
because it's also particularly true with
the mouth and the and the lips and the
tongue.
And then also the entire face,
because your face is extraordinarily
mobile and you broadcast emotion with
that and so it's a,
it's a communication device of the
highest order and so it has to be really
wired up.
You have so much neuro control over your
face that you can actually teach
yourself to fire single neurons in the
tissue underneath your eye.
So which you certainly not going to be
able to do with your back.
And then of course,
well why would you anyways,
so now,
so what I tell you that in part so that
you get some more understanding of how
the child is wired up because that
mouth,
tongue lip sort of arrangement that,
that,
that the baby is born with is very,
very powerful learning circuit and it's
established quite nicely right at birth.
And so then the baby can start exploring
the world using parts of it that are
already there.
And a big chunk of that is the mouth.
So,
and you know,
you know how this works.
Some of you have recently had dental
surgery of one form or another,
or at least you can remember when you
had it.
Maybe you had a tooth pulled or a
filling or you had racist put in or
something.
So one of the things you'll notice if
you lose a tooth isn't your damn tommy's
in there where the tooth was for the
next six months.
Right?
Fiddling around and you can do it
consciously,
which you will sometimes,
but even if you're not attending to it,
your tongue will be in there checking
out every tiny little crack and crevice
in the new area.
And what it's doing is updating your map
of the map of your body because your
mouth wants to know what part of it's
you and what part of it isn't.
Because first of all,
you're not supposed to chew the parts
that are you.
And second of all,
if there's any foreign body in the
mouth,
obviously you want to get that out of
there for endless numbers of reasons so
you can detect surface variation with
your lips and tongue with tremendous
accuracy.
And of course,
you know there's all sorts of uses that
people put that ability to.
It's also one of the ways that people a
test each other out for sexual
compatibility,
right?
Because that's all mouth and tongue work
rough.
Not all of it obviously,
but at least some reasonable proportion
of it.
And so that's also a part of exploratory
behavior.
So you're testing for things like health
with,
with kissing smell.
So anyways,
it's a major part of you,
you know,
and not only is it the part that you,
that you explore the world with so that
you can figure out what to eat and what
not to eat,
which is a big problem for omnivores,
right?
Because we can eat damn near anything
that's a complex cognitive problem,
but you also can use it as a tool for
exploring the contours of the world.
Now animals really do that with smell,
right?
Because your typical animal is a smell
based creature.
Whereas human beings aren't really so
much that probably because we became and
for a bunch of other reasons,
but smell is a tremendously powerful
modality and it's pretty much fully
there.
At birth as well,
and you know,
mothers report that they can distinguish
their baby by smell of virtually,
you know,
a day or two after they're born and they
know what the smell and babies can
certainly smell their mothers and their
fathers as well.
It doesn't take very long at all.
So anyways,
the baby's got its mouth and so it can
start getting somewhere with that.
And then it's also got basic reflexes,
you know,
and now what a baby does in some sense
is if it starts developing from the
middle and the top downward and outward.
So the mouth and the nose are all wired
up.
I start to get wired up fairly quickly.
They're not much to begin with because
the baby will move its eyes
independently and it's not very good at
focusing,
although it's focal length is actually,
it's natural focal length is pretty much
exactly the distance from breast to
mothers are,
which makes perfect sense,
right?
Because the baby wants to be able to
communicate extraordinarily well to
produce a bond with the mother.
And that happens most frequently with
during breastfeeding,
which is also extremely good for the
baby because the baby gets touched and
babies really,
really,
really need to be touched.
If you don't touch them,
they die.
So even if you feed them,
shelter them in all those sorts of
things,
they have to be touched and it's,
it's very good for the baby's
development.
So anyways,
the baby starts out with it's,
it's uh,
its ability to explore with its mouth
and its tongue in its and its ability to
smell and that it starts to develop its
eyes,
but it does that in concert with
developing other parts of its body.
No one.
So the baby,
if you put the baby on its stomach,
then it starts to exercise its ability
to lift up.
It's,
hey,
I didn't.
So it kind of gets that going and it
starts to learn how to use its arms and
its legs.
And um,
so one thing you can do for a baby
for example,
to help and get going.
So let's say the baby's in its crib,
it's laying face upward.
Okay?
You can give it a mobile.
How if you go into a baby store and you
look at mobile,
what you'll see as maybe the top part is
like to coat hangers,
right?
It's like a cross and then there's
things hanging from it and the things
will be,
I don't know,
maybe they're cute.
Who knows hello kitty things or some
damn thing like that,
you know,
and they're facing you.
Well that's a stupid mobile because you
aren't the person who's supposed to be
looking at the hello kitty thinks the
baby's supposed to be looking at it.
So those should be facing down and they
never are.
They're always facing sideways.
So when the baby looks at all it sees is
a bunch of horizontal lines.
So let's assume that you're reasonably
bright and you get one that the baby can
see and then maybe it should be black
and white or at least really,
really bright primary colors because
it's easier for baby could detect that
black and white.
It's really good because baby is pretty
good at detecting edges and so that
thing will move around the baby lay
there and watch it,
you know?
And and babies,
they,
I think they kind of look like they're
stoned on lsd
and I actually think that's technically
correct because one of the things that
hallucinogens do is reduced the
inhibiting power of memory on
perception.
And of course babies have no inhibiting
power of memory on perception because
they have no memory.
So there are pretty much completely
overwhelmed by the world all the time.
so they laying there watching this
mobile and you know,
you can shake it and maybe they'll have
a little reflex at that or,
or you can interact with somebody in the
baby will start checking that out and
we'll watch it and watch watching to the
watch party so that it can get its eyes
organized.
And it does that in concert to some
degree with its motor ability,
you know,
because you might say,
imagine your cross side a little bit
like the baby and you're looking at that
thing and there's two of them.
And you might think,
well,
how do you know there's not two of them?
And the answer to that is what?
You have to whack it with your hand as
soon as you walk with your hand,
you're going to find out if it's one
thing or two things.
Once you figure out whether that's one
arm or two arms,
you know,
and so the baby is starting to to whack
itself against the world and watched the
consequences to help it start to build
up its ability to interact with the
world and its ability to model the
world.
And so one of the things you watch,
for example,
if you put a baby in the crib and it's
got a mobile there,
you want to kind of move to mobile down
so that it's close enough so that the
baby might be able to bump it because
babies,
if you,
if you don't swaddle them,
they lay there and their hands and legs
sort of float in space like this.
And It's because they're not really very
well connected to them.
And that's why a baby will poke itself
and die now.
And then with his thumb and it's rather
amusing to watch and it kind of bleak
manner be.
So a baby will lay there and it'll poke
itself and will go like that.
And what it's just discovered is that
there's some relationship between that
random movement and that sensation.
Okay,
now,
okay,
so let's say it's laying there and it's
floating around in space and it's
fortunate enough so that it's leg comes
into contact with an element of the
mobile.
Well that will make the mobile do
something interesting and novel.
And when the bait,
when the mobile,
that's something interesting and novel
that triggers a reflex and the baby and
the and the reflex is that the baby will
orient towards it and look.
And so for piaget that was the circuit.
That was the beginning of the baby's
ability to sort of start bootstrapping
it up in the world.
And he thought what you needed was the
ability to move a little bit at least.
So that'd be the reflex say or even
randomness.
And then you needed the ability to
refine that movement.
So you needed to be able to practice it
and you need it to be able to improve
with practice and you need it to be able
to imitate.
And warming of the things that piaget
thought,
which I think is so smart,
it's so smart,
is that a lot of what babies did was
imitate themselves.
So for example,
maybe they're,
they're laying in bed and they're
starting to get some sense of the
connection between,
of how their arms and legs work and so
they can maybe make,
start to make sort of broad gestures and
that's it,
but now and then they are lucky in their
sort of flinging your arms around them,
they hit them all bile and they'd get a
little reflex out of that if it's a
startle and an indication of interest.
And then they'll sit there and practice
how to whack that thing with their hand.
And so then what.
So what they're doing is they kind of
accidentally produced a phenomena of
interest and they noted the consequence
and then what they do is try to
reduplicate the phenomena of interest.
So basically what they're doing is
manifest in different patterns of quasi
voluntarily read reflex plaza,
involuntary reflex of behavior.
And then if that produces something of
note,
they'll practice imitating it.
So when my daughter was about 18 months,
maybe not even at all,
13,
14 months,
maybe old enough to sit up anyways and
old enough to start to do some things by
herself.
We bought her these books.
They were disney books,
hardcover cardboard books,
you know,
five pages long or something.
Each of the pages was quite thick
because it was made out of cardboard and
they,
four of them would come in a little box
which is about four inches high and
about an inch and a half wide.
And if you really careful you could take
out the books and then you can put all
of them back in.
It wasn't that easy because the first
one wasn't too hard,
but they got,
you know,
consistently more difficult as you kept
putting each of the men because the
parameters of the exercise changed.
And she must have spent,
I don't know,
150 hours dumping those out,
picking them up,
putting them in.
And you might say,
well,
what was she doing?
And you know,
you'd say,
well,
she was putting books in a box.
That's not what she was doing.
First of all,
they weren't books to her and it wasn't
a box because she didn't know what a box
was,
what she was doing was practicing going
like this,
you know,
and matching the size of something to,
uh,
to the size of something else and not
very complicated and maybe you know,
so there is a jar of apple juice.
OkaY.
So you might say,
well pick that up.
Okay,
well you can pick it up like this.
You can pick it up like this,
you can pick it up like this,
you can pick it up like this.
Like there's a lot of things to
practice.
And each of those movements is a
different sensory motor capacity that
has an incredibly wide range of
potential applications.
So a child will sit there and fiddle
about their hands in their arms and the
rest of their body for untold hours
because what they're doing is building
up these basic sensory motor systems
from the bottom up so that they can,
you know,
so.
So they practice them in one domain
where there's some challenge and then
they're starting to build new
exploratory tools that they can go out
and practice on the rest of the world.
So you know,
once you can grip a,
I'd say once you can grip a mobile and
you can let go,
which is something babies actually have
a hard time doing because they have a
grip reflex and they're quite strong
when they're first born.
If you put your fingers in their hands,
you can lift them right off the ground,
the cling to you.
And that's probably old chimpanzee
gripping behavior because chimps grabbed
to their mothers first and then they're
like carried around like that for about
three years now.
Since you don't have much for.
It's kind of useless for the baby,
although they're pretty good at getting
your hair and your glasses and your
nose.
And so when you got to get them to let
go.
So anyways,
they'll sit there and practice all these
little sub routines.
And so you'll see this too.
If you have a baby,
you got your baby in the highchair,
maybe it's nine months old and you're
trying to feed the baby,
which is often very challenging because
babies are very curious and annoying and
troublesome and tough and ordinary and
exploratory and,
and misbehaving and provocative and all
those things because they need that to
learn about the world.
And they'll,
they'll do something like maybe they'll
eat and they'll drop the spoon and a
will go in the floor and they think,
oh,
gravity,
that's interesting.
So then you'll give them their,
their spoon again,
and the first thing they'll do is take
their food and finding it on the floor
and then they'll do that launch because
they're kind of interested in this whole
twisting the spoon and having things
fall on the floor phenomena.
And so it's part of the reason why it's
often hard to feed babies is because
even if they're hungry,
you feed them three things and then
they're not starving.
And then they're so hyper curious that
they're gonna,
you know,
try to do something else.
So,
but what they're doing is they're,
they're continually utilizing their
basic reflexive behavior and building
more and more complex structures up on
the basis of that and with each time
they do that,
it opens up a new toolbox for them and
they know,
expand outward and start to interact
with the world.
And so that's one way also of
understanding
where a baby's personality comes from.
Ali's is complicated because
there are things about babies that are
sort of
their parameters of personality or
somewhat determined at birth.
So I'll tell you how I conceptualized
this.
It's,
it's how you might conceptualize the
relationship between nature and nurture.
I don't know if this is a good metaphor
or not.
It's not the most elegant metaphor in
the world,
but it's worked for me.
So imagine for example,
that a baby at three months of age can
be a corn baby or nervous baby.
Now that is the case.
We know that even right at birth you
could kind of figure out whether a baby
is a baby or or nervous paypal.
that's neuroticism.
That's the fundamental dimension of
negative emotion.
So you might say that one baby's nervous
behavior might have this range and
another baby's nervous behavior might
have this range and another baby's
nervous behavior by cab,
this range and most of the time it sort
of in the middle of that range and now
and then it'll manifest behaviors that
are associated with what's extreme for
it.
So even if you have a calm baby,
sometimes it'll get upset and even if
you have a baby that's always upset,
sometimes it will be caught.
So then you might ask yourself,
well to what degree can you modulate the
baby's nervous behavior?
So let's say you want to have more calm
baby,
and so you're going to do some things to
make that baby calm.
The question is how much transformation
can you make?
And the answered that to some degree is
it depends on how much effort you make.
Some changes that are close to the
average of the baby's natural curve of
responses are fairly easy to make.
So you can shift the baby a little bit
towards being more calm without too much
work.
But if you want to shift it more towards
being calm,
then that's going to take more work and
if you're going to shift it more to be
calm,
that's going to take more work and it's
not linear.
So what happens is at some point you
kind of reach a practIcal limit.
You're not going to make your baby more
calm than you know.
Maybe you could move it one standard
deviation or two standard deviations
from its natural
resting place when it was first,
when it first emerged as a creature.
But if you're going to move it three to
three standard deviations from the fifth
percentile to the 95th percentile,
you're going to be working out.
You're not going to be doing anything
else with the baby.
So you can start to conceptualize the
relationship between nature and nurture
as a cost relationship.
So for example,
iq is quite stable,
but you can move iq,
but it's really expensive.
So there's a practical limit to it.
So I think if you take twins that are
adopted out at birth in order to get a
15 point difference in iq between the
twins,
by the time they become adult,
one twin has to be at the 95th
percentile for wealth in their family
and the other twin has to be at the
fifth percentile for wealth.
So that's a massive difference,
right?
It's huge.
And so it's such a big difference.
You're not going to produce that with
any degree of ease in the real world.
But so environmental transformations of
biological parameters,
cost,
that's a very useful way of thinking
about it.
So.
So anyways,
back to the baby.
Now
the baby is starting to organize itself
from the bottom up.
And so here's,
here's kind of a way to about how that
works.
Piaget pointed out that this is quite
well known in the development
literature,
that babies that are younger than three
don't really play well with others
and it's complicated because they can
play some things with others.
So for example,
you can play peekaboo quite well with
the nine month old,
you know,
so there's some sorts of simple games
that that babies can play with you
pretty much as soon as they get their
eyes focused.
And one of the funny things about babies
when they're very young,
even below nine months,
is that they already have a sense of
humor,
which is something I've never been able
to figure out.
So they can play a little comical games
with you as soon as you're smart enough
to figure out what the baby's up to
roughly speaking as they.
They appreciate humor absurdly early and
it's very difficult to understand why.
But anyways,
it doesn't matter.
The psg eddie and idea was in some sense
that what the baby does to begin with
his first plays games with itself.
So it's exploring,
you know,
and then it produces some phenomena of
interest and then it replicates that
until it masters it.
And then it just keeps doing that and
gets to be more and more and more
complex.
And then by the time it's about three,
it's complex enough so that all of its
little microsystems are kind of
integrated into one thing,
you know,
so it's got a set of routines for being
hungry.
It's got a set of routines for being
anxious,
it's got a set of routines for being
exploratory,
it's got a set of routines for seeking
attention from its parent and so on.
And then it starting to build some
overarching unity among all of those
micro processes so that it can segue
smoothly between them.
And you can really see this starting to
happen at two because you know,
you've heard of the terrible twos and
what happens in the terrible two's is
that the child is still fairly
unintegrated.
so they'll go there quite a riot to be
around because they're staggeringly
emotional.
You know,
they'll go from Guinea beyond belief to
crying outrageously,
too.
So angry that if you ever saw an adult
that angry,
you'd immediately run away and call the
police.
And they can do that like in 15 minuteS.
They just cycle through these things
very,
very rapidly.
So and,
and weirdly enough adults will notice
behaviors or they'll see behaviors in
children that would be absolutely
outrageous and adults and they don't
even really,
it doesn't phase them at all.
It shows you how well adapted we already
children because you know,
a child who's having a tantrum,
if the child is good at it,
you know,
they'll fling themselves onto the floor,
which you rarely see an adult do.
And then the pound and kick and scream,
and then if they're really good at it
and some of them get really amazingly
good at it,
they'll hold their breath until they
turn blue and pass out.
So I try that one night when you're,
you know,
when you don't have anything to do in
your color is off,
you know,
just see if you can kick and scream on
the floor for awhile and then hold your
breath until you turn blue and pass out.
You can't.
And that just shows you how committed to
the tantrum a child can be.
So it's easy to stop that sort of
behavior by the way.
So if your child throws a tantrum that
said home,
just go away and then eventually the
child will turn blue and pass out,
then they'll come to and there isn't
anyone there and that's not really an
exciting outcomes.
So if you do that two or three times,
the child usually figures out that it's
really not worth the hassle.
If you want him to choke,
to continue,
wait until they turn blue and pass out
and then really freak out.
Especially if you could do that randomly
a few times,
man,
you'll get that child just having
tantrums,
turning blue and passing out pretty much
everywhere.
So don't,
don't do that.
That's a bad idea.
So all right,
now.
So the got and idea in some sense is the
child builds up these little reflexes
and these little,
we'll call them subpersonalities because
it's a better way of thinking about it
and it starts to build them around.
Modern psychologists would think more
thAt it starts to build them around
motIvational systems.
Piaget would necessarily say that,
but,
and then at some point the child starts
to enter the social world.
Now it's simple in some ways to think of
the child before three is not social and
then the child after three is social,
but it's not really accurate,
right?
Because if you think about it,
the child is being social right from the
beginning of its development because
first of all it has to figure out,
for example,
how to feed even if it's not being
breastfed.
It Has to figure out how to participate
in a playful and social manner around
feeding and that's particularly the case
if the child has to breastfeed because
breastfeeding is very complex process.
First of all,
you have to get the mother to cooperate
and you can't fight her,
for example,
and so there's all sorts of rules about
breastfeeding that the baby has to
follow and so the babies actually
entering into fairly complex social
relationships in games right from the
beginning,
and that's especially true if it also
has siblings because if you have a baby
and maybe have a two year old,
the two year old and the baby are
playing right off the bat and they're
two year olds are amazingly good at
playing with newborns.
It's quite staggering to watch them and
so if you're thinking about having
children,
and I also recommend not just having one
because one child is way more work than
three because you have to amuse one
child all the time.
Whereas if you have three,
you can ignore them completely and
they'll just raise each other.
It's actually much better for the
children,
you know,
as long as you're there not to make sure
that they don't lie to each other on
fire and that sort of thing,
which is your basically your jaw.
So okay.
But we'll ask for the time being as if
the child isn't social till three
because that's simplification,
but it's a useful one.
So piaget was also extremely interested
in how the child became social and I
think apart from his ideas about,
you know,
the,
the self generation of the baby from the
bottom upwards using its own reflexes
and its own capacity to be explored.
The other thing that piaget was
extraordinarily good at
laying out and andy and remarkable at
discovering what's the role of games.
And so piaget was the first
psychologist,
I would say,
who discovered just how important it is
to have kids play.
Now,
the problem with players that it's fun
and so utilitarian people,
especially ones that are really
conscientious,
have this idea that if it's fun,
it can't really be good for you.
And so because of that,
the role of play in children was not and
still isn't appreciated in the full
dimensions of its importance.
So for example,
you know,
we take the kids that are in grade one
there like six,
you know,
what are we doing for them?
We put them in chairs like the ones
you're in,
you've been in that damn chair for like
16 years,
you know,
it's like we take those little
characters and we put them in chairs and
we expect them to sit there and listen
to adults for six hours a day while
it's,
it's so idiotic that it's beyond
comprehension.
It's no wonder tHe little gliders are
hyperactive,
you know,
that just means they're alive.
They shouldn't be taken out into the
school yard and supervised well playing
until they're completely exhausted.
Then they should have a little nap.
Then maybe you could teach them
something for awhile,
but
stopping them from playing on an or or
not facilitating play among them is
absolutely crazy because that's exactly
how children come to become social in
the world.
And the reason for that is that the
games children play are analogs of the
activities that adults engage in.
Well,
it's not that hard to figure it out.
Figure that out.
If you think about it,
I mean think about playing monopoly or
you're a teenager,
you play monopoly.
How many people have played monopoly?
Great.
Everybody's played monopoly.
Well,
what are you doing?
You're,
it's like evil capitalist pig gain,
right?
So,
and you know,
if you're going to grow up to be an evil
capitalist pig,
then you can get a good practice,
good practice going by playing monopoly
and you can,
you can become part of the one percent,
which is what you have to do to win,
right?
You need to have all the hotels and so
no one else has any hotels and you know,
you play that and it's fun.
It's fun.
So it's an analog of real life now.
It's an analog of real life in many ways
because most of the things that you do
with other people involve adhering to a
set of shared rules.
And most of the things that you do with
other people involve cooperating and
competing with them.
so if you're playing monopoly,
are you cooperating or competing?
How many people think competing?
Okay.
How many people think cooperating?
Okay,
you're cooperating.
Are you playing the same rules?
Are you playing by the same rules?
Well,
yes.
Unless you're cheating.
If you're cheating,
you're not playing monopoly,
right?
You're cheating.
ThAt's a different game.
So to play monopoly you have to
cooperate because you have to all agree
to sit in the same place.
You have to agree not to steal the
money.
You have to agree that the stupid rules
which are completely arbitrary,
are the ones that are going to govern
your life for the next,
you know,
two hours.
You have to agree to try.
You have to agree to try to have fun.
You have to agree to try to be like a
good player,
which means you don't get all sniffly
and whiny when someone,
when you land on someone's boardwalk and
they completely bankrupt you,
you know,
so you're cooperating like mad.
And another thing piaget pointed out,
which is absolutely lovely,
is that you can have a game without
cooperation and competition at the same
time.
So there's no such thing as cooperative
games.
You have to have for it to be a game,
it has to be competition within
cooperation or it can be cooperation
within competition,
within cooperation.
You know,
these things are very complex and the
nasty.
So if you're playing hockey,
for example,
is,
is hockey and aggressive game or come or
a cooperative game?
Well,
you have to play by the rules.
So both teams agree to that.
You're on the ice at the same time.
You don't bring a basket basketball,
you don't bring a chess game.
you're there to play hockey.
Are you cooperating or competing with
your teammates?
Well,
both,
right?
You're cooperating with them because you
want everyone to win.
Plus,
you want everybody to get better at
playing across time,
but you're competing with them because
maybe you can be the star of the game
and everybody's happy about that.
And then with the other team,
well,
are you cooperating or competing with
them?
Well,
as long as you're playing by the rules,
you're cooperating,
but there's obviously an element of
competition.
Now,
almost every human activity has those
elements.
There's a body of rules underneath it or
if they're not rules,
they're at least social conventions,
right?
There are things that people understand
are allowed and not allowed,
and then there's a competitive and a
cooperative element.
Alright,
so that's what children's start to
become particularly exposed to when
they're about three.
I'll piaget pointed out that there were
in some sense two classes of children's
games.
There was the games that have a really
clearly defined aim and that'd be the
goal and that'd be like,
you know,
in the little circles that we were
talking about,
that's where you're trying to go.
Now,
the thing about it being a game is that
all of you have to be trying to go there
at the same time and so what piaget
realized was that just as the child is
trying to integrate all their little
micro games inside them into some sort
of unified thing,
which would be the child,
a stable personality across time and
capable of weathering the storms of
life.
When a group of children get together,
they build another one of those
routines,
but it includes all of them and so the
kids might say,
well,
let's play hide and go seek.
That's a good one,
and everyone knows the rules to hide and
go seek and you can win or lose it
heightened,
go seek.
But what you're trying to do is you have
to bring your subpersonalities all the
way up to their integrated state
underneath a metal structure,
but that's organized by the collection
of children.
So the child would say,
well,
do you want to play hide and go seek?
And you're supposed to say you're either
supposed to say yes or perhaps positive
another game.
You're not supposed to freak out or get
angry or say that that's a stupid game
or run back to your mom because then
you're not going to be very popular and
you're not going to get to play,
and if you don't get to play well then
you're.
You're ruined because if you don't learn
how to play with others between two and
four,
you never learn and then you're some
poor outcast and maybe you end up in
jail or at least you end up like
isolated and and awkward and and poorly
socially integrated.
And that's not good because if you don't
get into the kids' games at three,
all of them start moving ahead and you
don't.
And the farther they've moved ahead past
you,
the less likely it is that they're going
to play with you.
So one of the things that's really worth
thinking about if you're going to have
kids is you have a job as a parent and
your job as a parent is to make your
child socially acceptable,
especially to other children by the time
they're three.
And if you don't do that well,
that's not very good.
You'll pay for it and so will your child
and you know,
there's been lots of longterm followup.
So on this sort of thing and it seems
pretty evident that if the kid isn't
socialized by
for then good luck.
There is no evidence at all from the
developmental literature,
which is quite a dismal literature that
you can fix that.
So anyways.
All right,
so the children don't get together and
they say,
well here's what we're going to do.
And everyone says yes.
And so they orient their personalities
towards that goal and then they interact
in a cooperative and competitive way in
pursuing the goal and that's a game and
what they're doing is practicing being
social human beings and so and they do
that with all sorts of different games.
and then you might say,
well here's something really worth
thinking about.
What does it mean to be a functional
human being?
It to me it means to be the sort of
human being that can be a good player
across multiple games.
So you might think,
for example,
you tell your kid,
I'll tell you the story,
but hockey game that I saw once
hockey parents say 10 percent of them
should just be jailed as soon as they
enter the arena.
So when my kid played,
I don't know what you'd call it,
a level
high level hockey for a while when he
was a kid anyways,
he was a good,
here's a good hockey player,
but it was really unbearable.
So we didn't do it for very long for a
variety of reasons.
But anyways,
on his way to learning how to play
hockey,
he was in one of these uh,
local leagues.
We had an arena just around the corner,
fortunately enough and he wasn't the
best player on the team.
There was a,
another kid on the team who was,
who is better,
I would save.
And uh,
he uh,
he was in a championship game at one
point.
He hadn't been in very many championship
games because there's teams often work
very good.
But anyways,
it was the local championship and we
went and watched and it was a really fun
game,
you know,
like it was really close,
I think if I think it was three,
three till the final 15 or 20 seconds,
and then some kid from the other team
scored a really good goal,
you know,
it was,
it wasn't one of those things where they
accidentally kicked the pocket into the
[inaudible] or something.
It was a really nice play.
And so it was a tight game.
The teams were well matched,
the local league had made sure like
they'd set up teams together and then if
one team kept winning to consistently or
one losing to consistently being sort of
revamp the team so they were roughly
equal,
which I really liked because,
you know,
all the kids got a reasonably equal shot
at it and everybody got to develop.
so anyways,
we were watching that.
It was pretty fun.
And uh,
they,
the star kid,
he was skating around out there and the
game ended and he went off the ice and
he smashed his hockey stick onto the
cement because he was all irritated and
you know,
which was pretty pathetic.
And then his father came running up to
him and said,
oh,
you got robbed.
It was really terrible,
you know,
the rafting was bad and you play it very
well and you should have won the game.
And he didn't say,
you know,
stop being a little rat and smashing
your hockey,
stick onto the cement like your three,
which is what he should have said.
He,
he
basically rewarded his child for
narcissistic,
a immature misbehavior.
So it was pretty pathetic.
Was child abuse as far as I'm concerned,
sort of up the second,
man.
That's stupid.
What are you going to do?
You're going to train your child to be a
narcissist.
That course,
that's child abuse.
It's moronic.
Of course it was due to his own
foolishness,
but I don't know if that's criminal,
right?
But it was really pathetic.
So,
but no,
but think about this now for a minute.
So you might think,
well what did that kid do wrong?
It's like,
well,
he wanted to win,
so that's okay.
You should want to win.
If you're playing a game.
I mean you're not any fun if you're
playing a game and you're not trying to
win and there's nothing more miserable
than playing a game with someone.
At the end of they say,
well you won because I wasn't really
trying.
It's like,
no,
you're not going to play with them again
if they do that.
And that's kind of interesting because
it means they've done something wrong.
No,
when even a kid can figure that out.
And so you might tell your kid,
be a good sport
and it doesn't matter whether you win or
not.
It matters how you play the game.
Now what the hell kid doesn't know how
to what to make of that and you hardly
believe it.
You think,
yeah,
it doesn't matter if you win.
So I don't know what this means,
but you'll tell the child that and so
then you might think,
well,
what does it mean to be a good sport?
And and that and that.
How you played the game is more
important than whether you win or lose.
Okay,
so think about it this way.
What's your goal?
Well,
you might say to win the hockey game,
but that implies you're only going to
play one hockey game,
but it's going to play 100 hockey games
and then forget about that.
What if you're going to play 100 hockey
games and 200 basketball games and 50
chess games and you're going to have a
bunch of jobs and you're going to have a
bunch of friends and you can have a
bunch of relationships and all of those
have a game like structure and let's say
that you're a real son of a bitch when
you play hockey and so no one ever
invites you to do any of those other
things.
It's like,
well,
you win the game,
but you lose the metagame.
The metagame is the game that's made up
of all the games you're ever going to
play and what a parent means when they
say it doesn't matter whether you win or
lose,
it matters how you play the game is that
the metagame is more important than the
game and you should learn how to play
games so that whether or not you win or
lose,
people really want to play with you
because if they want to play with you,
man,
you're set.
Right?
So here's,
here's a cool game.
So,
okay,
you two are going to play this game.
Are you ready?
Okay.
So here's the deal.
I'm going to give you $20.
You have to give some of that to him.
You want to get to offer once.
If he rejects it,
neither of you get anything.
Okay?
How much are you going to give him?
10.
Would you take that?
Okay?
Okay.
What?
Why?
I mean like these better than not
second,
clara maass,
right?
Yeah.
So here's.
This experiment is being done all over
the world.
And so basically what they find is that
people pretty much offer 50 slash 50.
Now here's something cool.
Let's say you go play this game and use
20 bucks in your planet with really poor
people.
And so you,
you set the game up.
So you say,
look,
offer him two bucks,
he's poor,
he'll take it.
So you offered to box,
what does he do?
He tells you to screw off,
right?
And he's more likely to do that if he's
poor.
So that's pretty interesting.
[inaudible],
like a classical economists would say,
look,
what you should've done was offered them
a dollar.
It's like you get 19,
you get 19,
he gets a dollar,
he's going to take the damn dollar
because it's better than nothing.
But thAt is more people are like,
it's like you give them a dollar and you
get 19,
they want to punch you,
right?
They're not going to take that.
And that's because they don't want to
play the game that way.
They want to play the game so that it's
fair across multiple games.
Now you might say,
let's say you're playing out in front of
a whole bunch of people like we were now
and let's say a whole,
all these people are going to be able to
invite you to play the same game and so
maybe you're going to be able to make
$400 in the next hour or so.
Then you might say,
well,
what should I do if I wanted everybody
to invite me to play this game as much
as possible,
then how much would you offer?
Fifteen.
15.
Exactly.
That's cool.
So that means actually you lost the
gate,
the one game,
right?
Because you only get 15,
five and he gets 15,
but like everyone's thinking,
hey,
I'm going to play it escape with her.
Well that's,
that's what it means when you tell
someone to play the game properly.
You say,
act as if while you're playing a
specific game that there's a higher
order moral principle that has to do
with the total number of games that
you're going to play across your entire
life and play that game properly.
Yeah,
well that's the evolution of higher
moral thinking in part from a piagetian
perspective.
It's bloody brilliant.
So right.
We'll see you tuesday.